[Music]
with the success of the first sonic the
hedgehog it came as no surprise that
paramount quickly greenlighted a second
film now that it's here critics have
started to weigh in here's what rotten
tomatoes reviews are saying about sonic
the hedgehog 2. following its theatrical
debut in january of 2020 the first sonic
the hedgehog movie ended up becoming the
highest grossing film adapted from a
video game of all time it was hardly a
shock then when its producers at
paramount publicly announced that they
had begun work on a second sonic movie
shortly after the premiere of the first
now that the second movie is here
reviews have begun surfacing online on
the whole opinions are mixed suggesting
that while existing sonic fans can't
expect more of what they liked about the
first sonic movie it's less essential
viewing for those with no interest in
the famous video game mascot here's what
some of the reviews collected by rotten
tomatoes have to say
quick stretch little snack and here we
go timeout reviewer ali richards awarded
sonic the hedgehog 2 a total of 2 stars
out of 5. he wrote most of the casts
work hard to sell a script peppered with
fart jokes and uninspired set pieces but
it's so chaotically plotted that it
quickly becomes exhausting in his review
for variety peter de bruges was
similarly critical of sonic the hedgehog
2 singling out its 2-hour run time as
feeling overly long and accusing
paramount of rushing the movie's
production according to debruce sonic 2
wears out its welcome well before it
turns into yet another phonetin
franchise entry comparatively author
carlos aguilar felt more positive about
the film as reflected in his review for
the rap he wrote proof that one can
elevate a mostly disposable franchise
investing in the casting and screenplay
sonic the hedgehog 2 doesn't harbor any
illusions of being a beacon of cinema
but within its department as the
harmless option for family viewing
drawing spring break it offers enough
surprises to be more pleasant than
unbearable like plenty of other aspects
of sonic the hedgehog 2 opinions about
its cast range from outright praise to
slight condemnation that said even some
reviewers that expressed a negative
opinion about the movie as a whole had
kind things to say about some of its
cast members in a moderately positive
review of the film for the hollywood
reporter justin lowe singled out both
jim carrey's performance as a villainous
dr robotnik and ben schwartz as a
titular sonic he explained his opinion
by saying kerry relies on an array of
facial tics enhanced by an outsized
mustache and erratic body language
characteristic of the expertly timed
physical humor that is perfected over a
series of similarly outlandish comedic
roles meanwhile schwartz nails animated
hedgehog's snarky impudent attitude and
unrestrained thirds for thrills even if
sonic's frequently frantic tone grows
increasingly worrying in the independent
clarice luffry praise schwartz's
enthusiasm for portraying sonic while
criticizing carey's performance she
explained he stands around trying to
turn bits of exposition into jokes by
gunning and over enunciating every line
ali richards meanwhile spoke more
positively about the cast in his review
for timeout praising schwartz kerry
james marston and tikka sumter alike in
his opinion the mvp however is natasha
rothwell as maddie's sister rachel whose
role is beefed up from the first film
another key component of sonic the
hedgehog 2 that divided reviewers is its
script overall some reviews singled out
its writing as one of the film's strong
suits while others shared pointed
critiques of its screenplay
you are terrible at this your negative
attitude is not helping for variety
peter de bruges praised the sonic 2's
screenwriting team's ability to adapt
the plot of a video game into a
film-ready story however he also
described the sequel as taking what was
endearing about the original in a word
personality and rendering it generic in
a hurry in his review for thr justin
lowe highlighted how the film's
formulaic structure results in a
rapid-fire series of big action
sequences in his opinion these sequences
sometimes underline the reliance on too
much over-the-top cartoonish action with
borderline bonkers plot development
breathlessly deployed at a clip
recalling the movie's video game origins
the rap reviewer carlos aguilar
meanwhile was kinder to the sonic the
hedgehog 2 scripts though he repeatedly
noted that it never transcends the fact
that it's in service of financial return
above all else compared to the first
film aguilar describes sonic 2 as a
similarly enjoyable cash cow with some
welcomed if far from revolutionary
idiosyncrasy
fans can judge for themselves when they
head to their favorite theater to watch
sonic the hedgehog 2.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you